I know that lots of women they look at
you know how much money my man is making
how much you know good good life yeah
you don't have to say money it could be
like whatever you look at for me it's
like having emotional support most of
everything and you know having someone
that you know understands my needs you
know my ornamental level obviously you
know we need to you know do life
together and navigate you know
challenges and everything but ultimately
for me it's about finding that
compatible person which is very
difficult to do because you know you're
gonna have always something you know
that some character traits that are not
really you know men and women are just
different and as much as we want to play
this car oh I want to be like a man I'm
never going to be a man I wasn't born a
man and I'm not gonna understand what a
man's